you don't have to be a senator to make a
difference all you have to do is care
and I would hope that and and this is
something which is enormously inspiring
now because what I go to schools and
colleges I find so many of the young
people want to be involved in helping to
solve the problems maybe not running for
elective office but in trying to solve
the problems we've seen that in national
magazines in recent times and one of the
very very important parts of an
education bill that we have just passed
in the House and Senate the president
sign will be loan forgiveness for
students who generally have twenty
thousand dollars of indebtedness when
they graduate some much more but it'll
be loan forgiveness for those that want
to be involved in working in their
community to help solve the problems
maybe as a teacher maybe as a nurse it
may be as a prosecutor maybe as a legal
defender maybe as a child care worker
may be working with special needs of
children may be working on an Indian
Reservation we've been very broad in
terms of what we have defined on that to
try and to say to the young people of
this country you know if you're a person
that is able to get admission to a
school and college costs should not be
the barrier for you and when you
graduate debt should not be a barrier
for your ability to make a contribution
to the country to give something back to
the community for all that is given to
you and from something to give back to
the nation that's the kind of spirit is
alive and well gets back to your earlier
question about the state of our
democracy as long as that kind of spirit
is out there this country will be safe
you